uh
so i do have something and it's been a
while
um now mike and i have always been very
open and honest that we were fans of
opie and anthony
you know being anthony put patrice on
when
bill burr was funny and stuff like that
show was one of the best shows i mean
very funny stuff some of the best bits i
mean just great show
even mention you know bother the media
they started the whole attack on the
media thing which was hilarious and all
that stuff
um i think
i wanted to check in on opc how he's
doing
do you want to check in on opie sure
let's check in on opie
jesus christ he looks
he looks like i don't mean this
objective i know obviously
we are not fans of opie we've been
pretty crucial to vopey but
this is for him this is even for him
this is bad
he looks bad
well let's see what let's i thought it
was pharrell no
this is opie um this video looks like
now
uh david butcher when's the last time
you spoke to anthony and jimmy yeah well
i started taking phone calls from
anthony when i did the um
the new show with carl and vic and
charlotte
those were going very very well we did
five or six of those and i felt like
there was a path to keep the ona brand
together yeah and then the show was so
bad it killed
everybody on it yeah also i got to give
props to opie i mean look
we can [ __ ] on them all we want it's a
nice view
that's a nice view that's uh you know
all right
god damn it's a nice view i wasn't i
felt like there was a path to keep the
ona brand together
um but they were moving very very quick
on their end and they really wanted us
to move over to
anthony's joint and i felt like it
wasn't the right place for me
so i i turned it down and then um that's
my recollection and then um you know can
you ask a question
sure i'm looking outside it's nighttime
right
why is he wearing sunglasses
because he's cool bro oh i think about
that angle
then the hate got really really really
bad after that and continues
unfortunately to this day
so um as far as anthony goes yes ma'am i
talked to him for the last time
on the phone four or five years ago i
haven't seen him in person in
seven and jimmy
now ready for this thing that totally
really happened
i know you heard it i know so did i but
i want everyone else in this thing that
totally really happened ready
ever told this story so jimmy uh works
out at the gym i work out at
and uh i was leaving uh the locker room
and i opened the door and uh
it was jimmy i don't know if i ever told
you guys this
and i my natural reaction was so he was
coming into the locker room and i was
leaving
and this was the first time i saw him in
uh i don't know a couple of years
and uh i swear to you
all i could bust her up it was just a
natural reaction i just went
really really loud you know when a kid's
making up a story
and they go i swear to you and they stop
five times ago and i swear this is what
yeah
and then walked by him and and uh left
the gym so i
i guess that was the last time i talked
to jimmy
were you laughing but that was my
natural reaction
also he tells that story like i went uh
like as if
he's making it sound like he beat his
[ __ ] ass
front i really go bro i couldn't control
it i can't be stopped
i wonder what i would say if i saw him
or whatever and and
what came out was just uh
let's see uh whoa the comments are
flying by
whoa man yeah interactive you should
have threw a protein bar at the worm's
liver spotted head
you're a savage opl jacob did he respond
jimmy i swear to have no idea
that would be no no you wouldn't know
you remember the story fondly that would
be one of the things again then jimmy
said this
yeah i can recall any i can recall
altercations i've had
very easily because they're altercations
because usually your adrenaline's
pumping
you remember everything you know i have
no idea what he said to me
i think he was in shock that he was just
opening up the door and i was on the
other side
and i i blew past him pretty fast with
my
i'm sure knowing jimmy as much as i
used to i should say i'm sure i'm sure
he
uh he had a retort but i honestly can
tell you i did not hear anything but i'm
sure
i'm sure when he realized what the [ __ ]
was going on he had a quick
something something to say but i blew by
him
so freaking awkward yeah brian bernard
it was really awkward but it's kind of
funny
now that's funny is it though
andy come on now uh
he obsessed over that for weeks
guaranteed ah probably
[Music]
probably probably
forget about are we can i say it
i'm
i'm worried about opie too
right like he used to be funny to make
fun of opie but like
this is one of those like somebody needs
to reach out
to him because he's not he's not well
about who you dislike dude focus on the
future make good on the past i i've made
good on the past
i've taken a lot of responsibility and
um
a lot of the things when um i really
like what i do now
you mean there's nothing you do nothing
now here's the thing
i obviously never out anybody but i
could tell you with and you know i'm you
know i'm not making this up
mike mike could tell you with 100
certainty that i
do know people that worked very closely
i know people
i'll tell you guys who his league is uh
very closely with with opie with anthony
and with jimmy
and i'll tell you this
definitely not him he's bffs with danny
ross daddy ross has been feeding him
involved
and he hates me um you really [ __ ]
can't stand me
but no you don't like my eskimo brother
danny ross
come on continue i'm sorry um
well that would make you and anthony
eskimo brothers too i i also got to go
to an event where i got to meet a lot of
cia people
fbi no it was a it was a whole
thing oh oh oh
it's like they're realizing it's a
lesbian bar oh
so i'm from someone that used with not
one person with a few people used to
work with them and i could tell you this
with 100 certainty
opie was going behind people's back
people that were
were loyal when they were in that rift
right towards the end they're having
that rift
opening opening opie went behind
people's backs
and was going to hr in management
and complaining about people that were
[ __ ] completely
loyal to opie since day one that
defended him
all the time against all the [ __ ]
and then
when he left all of those things became
public knowledge about like hey here's
the complaints that were being filed
against you
from opie he was doing this to people
around him behind the scenes for a long
long time very specifically during the
opie and jimmy days
which is weird because yeah maybe that
was just when he started spiraling
because i mean i know he was always a
prick but
the whole anthony leave you know the
whole anthony getting fired thing really
just
it was like watching a [ __ ] wing blow
off of an airplane it was like
okay everybody's going down with this
thing but he started really being a
[ __ ]
and then remember keep in mind i want to
remind everybody that opie was fired
um the ultimate decision to do so was uh
after opie was
filming their talent booker roland
taking shits in the bathroom and then
playing it on the air
yes and like everybody was like you
can't like
and this was in like what 2016
2017 or 2015 maybe this was not like
you know 10 years ago and shock jockster
like
he was filming an employee in the
bathroom
and he was like whoa it was a funny bit
and everybody was like
and then even even roland was like
pissed off at him of course
and he was trying to make it out like
roland was unreasonable like
whoa what's your problem dude what we do
it for the goof and i'm like look man
there's a lot of [ __ ] we all do to goof
on each other but i would flip
if somebody filled me in the bathroom as
i'm sure you would because there's just
certain times where it's like
wait you're waiting for me to have my
pants down i was taking a [ __ ]
like that to me is like a weird
vulnerable thing where it's like
you filmed me [ __ ]
um it's hard though man i'll be honest
with you it's really really hard people
hit me up with this [ __ ] um all day long
if i go on social media it's all day
long
yeah i know i know a lot of people who
whenever they go online and they're
famous for one thing
because they accomplished one thing um
there's a lot of people that um bother
them about the one thing
like for instance um ringo starr
is a great example of somebody that is
going to if he's going to go on a talk
show
they're going to ask you beetle
questions they're not going to you
ringo's stars
all star band with two r's uh they're
not gonna ask questions about that
uh to to borrow from uh your your buddy
jimmy's favorite band kiss
you're not gonna have uh peter chris or
[ __ ] paul stanley come in
because they're promoting their book and
just ask them questions about their book
you're gonna be like so when you were in
kiss
what was this like you know what i mean
like nobody gives you [ __ ] about you
yeah you could come on and promote your
other things but yeah
just get ready op get ready to spend the
rest of your life
fielding opie and anthony related
questions on twitter because that's all
you did that's all you have
be grateful be grateful because a lot of
people live and die without even having
so much as that in life like
you for a guy of limited talents
managed to work the system pretty well
for yourself
be grateful honestly i'm on the social
media
less and less especially twitter
twitter's just garbage
it's just an absolute cesspool
how did you not laugh in his face it was
just a natural reaction was just to be
like
so you said you decided to do a colin
quinn impression when you saw norton
yeah god oh and i said god too
oh god did you go oh he also remembered
that he said oh god
yeah did you say uh yeah what are you uh
what are you working on a leg day stupid
did you also do that
did you say that to him on the way out
what's up what are you what are you
doing
that's kind of working on your your core
or something dummy
because i was so mad i'm like ow
really do you know why are you mad do
you know how likable well not likeable
but do you know how redeemable he'd be
if he just came out and said you know
what dude
well no if he did that everybody would
say he was coughing bobby kelly you know
what dude yes
but he should come out and say i'm a guy
who coasted through life with
very limited talents but i was able to
get some of the funniest guys in the
world together
and i was able to use that to negotiate
great deals for us
and you know what three mediocre guys
became [ __ ] huge radio stars off that
but i will admit that i made a lot of
money i probably didn't deserve all of
it but here we are
you know what i don't even think people
get mad but he still clings to this like
like like he was he was one of the guys
man he was in the patrice documentary
for three seconds so i know i saw that
um but he it's not enough for opie to
just say you know what we had a great
run
and considering where i should be in the
packing order of life i'm just grateful
that
i made as much money as i did and i got
out with my health
and whatever but he can't help himself
he has to constantly like yeah those
[ __ ] guys right aren't they pieces
and shit's like get over it
this is like a guy you can't get over a
[ __ ] real breakup
it's like when you have a friend that
like when you have two friends right
and they're dating and you meet them as
a couple but you're friends with both of
them
and then they break up and then one of
them starts going i want you to be
friends with her
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know what she
did and you go like look i'm not going
to be
hanging out with her alone or anything
and i'm not certainly not going to be
going on dates with her but like
if i'm at a party and she's at a party
i'm not going to be like get her the
[ __ ] out of here
she cheated on my friends like it's none
of my business dude